in deutschland im jahr 2021 wird die
kirchenglocke geschlagen um die menschen
nach zu wecken damit sie nicht ertrinken
was löst das bei dir aus ja erst einmal
dankbarkeit für den mann der da so
gehandelt hat für den pastor der da so
gehandelt hat und die menschen mit den
kirchenglocken noch versucht hat zu
warnen im rahmen seiner möglichkeiten
wir haben in den letzten tagen gehört
dass eine bürgermeisterin in adenau als
letzte katastrophenschutz maßnahme die
er noch blieb den örtlichen priester
angerufen hat und ihn gebeten hat zu
beten für die menschen in ihrem ort weil
sie niemanden gefunden hatte den
katastrophenfall ausrufen und alarm
auslösen könnte und dieses thema alarm
auslösen ist das was mich in den letzten
tagen beschäftigt hat mir ist da nach
dieser katastrophe tatsächlich einen
skandal bewusst geworden der geradezu
atemberaubend ist und der tatsächlich
menschenleben gekostet hat nämlich dass
wir mit steuergeldern uns einen
großartigen katastrophen waren dienst
leisten nämlich den deutschen
wetterdienst der behörde die bezahlen
wir alle während wir stehen und geld
verdienen und sozusagen steuern
generieren mit unserer arbeit
finanzieren wir die menschen die auch
gewarnt haben vor dieser situation vor
dieser fluggäste situation nun wird es
aber ab soll das deutsche gesetz erlaubt
es nicht dass man mit den informationen
für die wir bezahlen die uns schützen
sollen uns schützt und uns diese
information flächendeckend und auf dem
schnellstmöglichen wege mitteilt nämlich
ganz einfach auf das handy das
heutzutage jeder hat nicht auf das
smartphone übrigens das smartphone hat
noch nicht jeder viele alte leute haben
kein smartphone viele leute alte leute
haben keine apps wissen nicht wie man
apps runterladen kann
aber was jeder kann ist eine sms empfang
und das ist in deutschland tatsächlich
derzeit aus datenschutzrechtlichen
gründen nicht erlaubt und ich frage mich
wie kann das eigentlich sein ist es in
den letzten tagen viel über sirenen
geredet worden fragt denn der staat die
bürger die vielleicht hörgeschädigt sind
oder in tinnitus haben die sich
vielleicht gestört fühlen könnten vom
sirenen geräusch ob er diese rena
einschalten darf nein natürlich nicht
die warnung wenn es um leib und leben
geht ist das wofür wir den start
und dieser staat hat es verboten die
effizientes mögliche warnung
auszusprechen und nicht nur hat das
verboten
gestern hat unser reporter peter wilke
die bundeskanzlerin gefragt ob wir das
nicht ändern sollten ob wir nicht
schleunigst dieses cell broadcasting den
alarm per sms in alle betroffenen
gebiete broich und das in dieser
situation können wir auch einmal
reinhören und zwar wie peter wilke unser
bild reporter die bundeskanzlerin darauf
angesprochen hat dieter wilke von bild
frau bundeskanzlerin bei dieser
katastrophe konnten viele menschen nicht
rechtzeitig gewarnt werden durch
sogenannte cell broadcast in die
flächendeckende nutzung von sms hätte
das möglich sein können war aber jetzt
aus daten zu gründen nicht möglich
der bundesverkehrsminister heute morgen
schon bei bleib bei uns gefordert das zu
ändern dass er sich dafür stark machen
möchte meine frage an sie wäre
wollen auch sie dafür sorgen dass das
möglich ist menschen rechtzeitig warnen
zu können was jetzt hier etwas leben
retten können sie das vielleicht sogar
versprechen es hat ja warnungen gegeben
der deutsche wetterdienst und auch das
bundesamt für bevölkerungsschutz hat
gewarnt jetzt könne man über die
verschiedenen mechanismen sich lange
auch debattieren
wir haben dieses modulare warnsystem von
denen kommen alle informationen an die
lokalen behörden ich glaube das ist auch
richtig so
was sollten wir nicht zentralisieren und
wir haben
also wie man auf dem smartphone nutzen
kann zum beispiel nina
die haben den vorteil dass sie noch
genutzt werden können wenn man wlan hat
in der eigenen wohnung während die sms
benachrichtigung über die sie jetzt
gesprochen haben die wir zum beispiel
anwenden bei flugreisenden die fällt
natürlich aus wenn das mobilfunksystem
ausgefallen ist dann haben sie auch
keine möglichkeit über sms zu wahren und
das ging zum teil rasend schnell
dennoch gibt es schon verabredungen weil
auch das bbk das bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenschutz sich das vorgenommen
hatte sich das noch mal anzugucken
mit diesem cell broadcast dass man dann
punktgenau bestimmte funkzellen warnen
kann und die telefonanbieter bieten ist
es jetzt in deutschland nicht an
aber ich glaube auch da ich habe gerade
mit an die steuer gesprochen über diesen
tragen
scheinen sich veränderungen anzubauen so
dass auf jeden fall sehr zeitnah
gespräche stattfinden könnten ob wir das
zusätzlich machen aber wir haben ein
sehr gutes warnsystem von dem
frauenhofer gesellschaft hat waren heißt
dass wir haben einen diese app nina die
jetzt auch noch mal sehr erweitert wird
und insofern glaube ich müssen wir dann
schau machen was hat geklappt was hat
nicht geklappt
aber vergessen wir nicht dies ist ein
hochwasser wie es lange lange nicht
gegeben
ich glaube man hat in der zeit auch noch
mal erlebt man denkt hat es geht digital
man wird auch das analoge wieder
brauchen wir haben lange sirenen nicht
mehr gehabt weil man dachte die
kriegsgefahr ist wegmann hat sie
vernachlässigt ich glaube in einer
solchen gesellschaft wo man merkt wie
vulnerable die gesellschaft ist wenn der
strom plötzlich nicht mehr da ist
da werden wir auch analoge mittel
brauchen und dass werden bund und länder
die hier enger zusammenarbeiten müssen
auch mit dem amt für katastrophenschutz
nach der krise analysieren um beim
nächsten mal noch besser vorbereitet zu
sein
vielleicht ist die gute alte sirene doch
plötzlich als wir gedacht haben
ja wir haben es gerade gehört unsere
bundeskanzlerin sieht weniger
handlungsbedarf bei uns ist noch bild
chef julian reichelt wie schätzt du das
ganze ein ja aus meiner sicht gerade vor
dem hintergrund der trümmer in denen die
bundeskanzlerin da steht auf
erschreckende weise aus rethen ausreden
ausreden
die kanzlerin sagt wir haben ein sehr
gutes warnsystem in der wahrnehmung
aller menschen in diesem land tut ein
sehr gutes waren system genau eine sache
es warnt in diesem fall hat es angeblich
sehr gute warnsystem aber eines nicht
getan gewarnt in diesem fall sind
menschen jämmerlich ertrunken in ihren
schlafzimmern weil das angeblich sehr
gute waren system eines nicht getan hat
nämlich gewarnt und die ganze
argumentation die ich da höre sie lässt
mich wirklich schaudern
denn die kanzlerin sagt uns tatsächlich
wir müssen darüber nachdenken ob es
sinnvoll ist ein warnsystem einzuführen
was ja unter gewissen umständen dann
nicht mehr funktionieren könnte das
etwas nicht mehr funktionieren könnte
kann ja aber niemals grund sein wenn es
um leib und leben geht es nicht
überhaupt erst einmal einzuführen und
ich finde es muss schluss sein mit
dieser gelassenheit in deutschland und
gelassenheit damit technologien die
menschenleben retten können nicht
einzusetzen wir waren sehr gelassen und
entspannt und unsere bundesregierung war
jetzt anderthalb jahre sehr gelassen und
entspannt dass wir in unserem
gesundheitsämtern zu großen teilen über
nur über faxgeräte verfügen dass wir
über corona nicht das wissen was über
kroner wissen müssten dass sie die
unsere bundesregierung hat es über fast
zwei jahre pandemie nicht geschafft alle
gesundheitsämter an ein einheitliches
system anzuschließen da sind immer noch
nach meinem kenntnisstand um die 100
gesundheitsämter in deutschland einfach
nicht angeschlossen
da war die regierung sehr gelassen im
umgang mit technologien die
menschenleben retten können und jetzt
zeigt sie dass in einer akuten sehr
dramatischen lage eben schon wieder
ja es gibt da ein warnsystem aber wir
müssen erstmal gucken ob wir das wollen
ob das geht und eigentlich ist es ja gar
nicht so schlecht gelaufen doch es ist
verheerend schlecht gelaufen wie
verheerend schlecht sieht man an den
ungefähr 160 grabsteinen die wir nach
dieser krise aufstellen wir müssen an
all den zerstörten städten die wir sehen
und mein punkt hier ist ein ganz
einfacher
das einmal nicht umzusetzen menschen zu
wahren ist aus meiner sicht ein grund
dafür politische verantwortung zu
übernehmen und einen grund für einen
rücktritt
es muss für so was politische
verantwortung übernommen werden an
geeigneter stelle einmal dieser
verantwortung nicht nahe zu kommen ist
ein rücktrittsgrund zweimal beim
nächsten mal und das nächste mal wird
kommen dieser politischen verantwortung
nicht nachgekommen zu sein ist kein
grund für einen rücktritt sondern ein
grund für einen richter weil der staat
ist verantwortlich für menschen und wird
vertrauen uns dem start an und der stadt
kann uns nicht sagen es gibt da eine
technologie die können wir bei corona
einsätzen auch dass der unions jetzt
erzählt wird das ist bisher noch nicht
möglich ist natürlich totaler quatsch es
ist einfach quatsch es ist möglich bei
corona im infektionsschutzgesetz hat der
staat ist möglich gemacht menschen die
deutschland betreten zu sagen hallo
achtung ihr befindet euch jetzt in
deutschland haltet euch bitte an
folgende regelungen natürlich ist es
möglich wenn unsere regierung ist wollte
und deswegen sollte sie aufhören den
menschen zu erzielen dass es aus
irgendeinem grund nicht möglich ist und
die information zur verfügung zu stellen
die wir bezahlen die wir brauchen die
menschen leben retten aller letzter
punkt sale broadcasting aus meiner sicht
die sms an alle menschen in einem
gewissen gebiet die technologie die wir
nicht nur aus katastrophenschutz gründen
für die zukunft dringend bräuchten und
die wir längst haben sollten es gibt
noch mindestens zwei ganz dramatische
szenarien für die sehen wir sie auch
brauchen
das erste sind terror und amok lagen
bleiben sie drin ist befinden sich
terroristen auf der straße das zweite
und das ist mir persönlich das
allerwichtigste entführte kinder in den
usa amber alert ein viertes kind in
einer gewissen gegend sms an alle
menschen die sich in dieser gegend
befinden haben sie dieses kind gesehen
dass ein land wie deutschland dazu nicht
in der lage ist weil wir diese einfache
technologie angeblich nicht zur
verfügung haben und jetzt auch noch vor
dem hintergrund dieser trümmer erklären
dass das eigentlich gut ist dass wir
diese technologie nicht zur verfügung
haben empört mich wir sind bild und wir
liefern dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren